Okay
Everybody. Thumbs up, welcome clap it up. Welcome back to ASS
Animal Super Squad, the greatest game of all time,
which I made completely by myself. I'm taking all the credit for all the work that has been done.
Why not just keep playing this ten out of ten game of all time?
Critics are calling this the greatest acompliment(bruh)...
accomplishment in humankind, and I would have to agree(chicken falls through logs) god damn it
Oh I'm fine! How about that? There's many possibilities in this game, endless possibilities, oh there's a map there
Here we go, just need the right speed and momentum.
There it is, there it is, we got it. What is this? chumpy jumpy? There's just so many ways to go in the game
look at that beautiful look at that front flip I
I did it
And we're back up on top, as we always are
Come on little puffer, you can do this damn it
He is getting his ass beat(chuckles). Oh no!
Here we ar, oh wow. We're fine
We're absolutely fine. Poor lil puffer. He dindu nothin. All right, thank God, a checkpoint
I'm fine. I don't think I'm supposed to go there. Okay, whatever. (exoplodes), god damn it
There it is, okay I get. I got to stand on the platform. My goal is to be
Jacksepticeye. If I beat his score, then I know I have done a great job. Oh
my god, I think I'm okay. Alright another checkpoint nice. Yeah, you know I might be a little biased, but these levels are well-designed man
Look at that. Okay, we're going up to the top. Hey!, look at that.
Great. Come on. I gotta be Jacksepticeye. I'm gonna check what score he gets later.
Fuck, that's annoying
Why does that keep happening! Alright, let's take and nice easy
Nice and easy, you got a time it.
You got a tie, you gotta time it
You got it. You got a time it, you gotta time it
For real how long did Jack take. There it is, there it is, he's there in two minutes 18. I'm there (realizes) oh no
I gotta beat Jack
That's all I care about now
If I don't, then this game has been for nothing. I did it I did it
Whoa what the heck?
What is this?
How does this even work
NOOOOO!
Oh, it charges! I see, I see. You hold it down. wuuuooh!
Look at that. I knew about that. I knew about that.
I knew about that as well. I knew about everything because I made everything in the game. Let's get the checkpoint
Charge it baby, come on!
Maybe too much power. Maybe not
God damn it. C'mon, I don't have enough time to fail, come on, come on
Come on
Come on. Oh, there's a flame there, there's a flame there everybody
Look at that. Look at it
Perfection.
Let's get the perfection everybody alright, then we go down we go yes
Come on
The game, the levels are getting a lot harDEERR
F*ck, come on, I gotta beat Jack I gotta beat  Jack I gotta beat Jack come on come on come on come on
Come on, yes, that's an unlock, you know what? I need the hovercraft, come on
Here we go here we go here we go
Come on, yes yes yes. HUH(inhale)
What!? No?
You @ssholes
Okay
5:46 well well well I bet I bet you know he didn't even beat the level
five (Jack- fuck my face)eleven
(Jack - no don't fuck my face). Pewds- What the hell, I thought he was family friendly Christian
I'd literally just clicked there, and that's what you said Jack.
5:54, you got your beat buddy!  Suck on that one Jack. Suck on how bout dat
Jack, I didn't even try I didn't even try. Moving on,  ooh there's a star level
Jumpy jumpy oh, that's the thing we unlocked okay, let's try it what didn't then what I?
Need to get oh it's like a I need to I need to jump on the thing - are
You kidding me - how now I need to go back a little bit
Well
That's impossible oh I know how I know how oh
I get it just ignore that
Was easy that was easy we got corn dog everybody let's go to crystal and pipes come on
Come on
Easy, I gotta be Jake again, man. I got so much bag
Look at that speed. Go home. You Irish something bad. Okay? Yes
Look at it
I'm pumping the speed I'm pumping the speed the hell are you smoking jacket? What happened to you you fell up?
You fell off Jack
Why am I so mean to Jack at him I?
Have no reason to okay. You know why I'm starting toward a drama for the sake of promoting this game
Wow, I really did it guys. I really man
I can't see where I'm going. I'm sure it's I'm here now. I'm here now
Nailed it no no no no miss no no no oh
Yes, this machine is the best dude there it is
Yes, we really went for realistic physics. You can tell right. It's so nice here. We go look at that boy
Look at this boys easy excuse me excuse me can the game be a little more easy. What's happening?
Okay right, you know what I'm gonna bet my youtube channel. Oh you thought you could make me fall down
I'm gonna bet my youtube channel. I'm beating Jack in this game
And I'm not even trying
Get me out there it is
Ladies, and I go hey look at that. That's awesome very nice
219 what did Jack get three years
The air and wave them like you just don't care
3:55 well I think we know who the casual is. I want to play some of you guys maps
These are my maps I sort by likes jungle escape got a lot of likes, so let's go with that one
Let's see what you guys have made in the game. It's actually decent looking man. It's like well-designed and everything
Wow, it's almost like you guys have some form of talent
I'm really impressed you guys made this. Oh look at that. It's got a different option
Oh my God look at that get the checkpoint and a front-flip. Thank you
Wow, I really misjudged you guys I did. I thought you would make really bad levels bidding. These aren't up. Oh wow
Oh, wow, oh wow oh?
Oh my god. This is awesome. Okay here Brad
Not again
What is happening whoa whoa nope no no no too fast too fast. Oh
My Oh No ever again, we did that was awesome that was so cool
I gotta like that one. I got unlike that one man Supremes
Rollercoaster zero deaths I'll be the judge of that
What the heck what is this vehicle oh wow hey
Come up
Come up come on give me the speed mr. Puffer
Wait what's happening? Oh my god? Oh my god. I'm fine. I'm fine ow
Nice
Nice I do that on purpose
Look at this oh
Shit, we've burned up
Ok we're almost there. We're almost there. Don't worry. We're gonna make it to the top
No no no it's fine, I'll make it to the top don't worry about
Don't worry about it. Don't worry about it. Don't worry about it ok
Shut up
I'm fine. I'm fine. I'm fine. I'm fine. Don't worry about me
This game is clearly bullshit this game has given up on me
how
That what
We're fine, we're fine, we're fine I missed the checkpoint are you kidding me?
Fifty meters 50 meters, I just need to go 50 meters how
And then we're done, okay come on come on
Just put me down
Just put me down here. Please oh, no we're still here
Come on just
ten meters
Alright, we're fine
We're fine. We're fine. We're fine. I actually did it
Rake up gaming well done designing that level I really enjoyed it very hard level four very hard whamon
I'll be the judge of that
All right, what do we got huh? What did we get huh? All right?
What did we get very easy level four very tough, man. It's what I'm getting in. I'm you know
I'm not even gonna get the checkpoint cuz I know I don't need oh my god. Oh wow wow
wow
It's fun. Oh wait. It's the boat thing again. No wait what?
I'll jump over any day son this machine is Opie nerf nerf this one you guys thought you could give me a challenge
please
You guys are a bunch of wimps
Come on. Seriously guys if you want to make a hard level all you have to do was ask ow
That's fine
happens to everyone
That's fine that happens to everyone
There's two speed
skip the checkpoint no problem
Look at the speed speed and momentum, baby
Okay, I did that on purpose oh
No, oh we're fine
We're a little move not adjusted properly, but we're fine
Okay the arrow says this way and the arrow didn't mine oh
My god what in the world oh?
My god what how long is this level dude? Oh? Oh wow ah
Damn it
There it is
Like a marinated sauce that's been marinated look at that
This is no sauce no ketchup
just sauce
Okay, we're here now. I don't know if I'm supposed to be okay. You know what the level got a little harder
I'll give you that but that is this is my first try after all
So I really appreciate all you got to land on the coop fuck fuck fuck fuck. Yep. Oh
It's fine. I don't I don't need two propellers. No damn it
You guys are a bunch of wham and disrespect her. I knew it. I knew it since the beginning
Says, I knew it was a bad idea to like you guys make the levels. I knew it was a bad shit
Oh, no, are you kidding me if you want to get good at this game? You got it?
You gotta at least respect five times a day
easy
No Felix go back to the cloud go back to the cloud Kingdom there we go
remember the key
speed
is weed
fuck I
Think I'm not gonna make it I think I'm not gonna make it and that's really fucking annoying
Get the other clown get the other clown. Oh
Yes, yes, it's all. Thank God. Okay, all right
It's happening
There it is oh
Wow, this game is so hard guys wow so hard you really did me a challenge. I am so scared
Come on
Here we go
Damn it
There it is like a marinated sauce that's been sauced
Am I right ladies you know what I'm talking about ladies the whamon all five of you that watch this channel really appreciate you
Talking yes look at that scale the Swedish man skill
Good someone to do a mountain climbing map with this
But this one that'd be funny no I flew past the goal
That's a fake goal isn't it oh?
That's a fun level I enjoyed that Christian Channel everyone
Well what what's happening I need to go down what happened to gravity man
Wow what a great level
Cristen channel everyone in credit wait the goal is in the middle. I see it I see it oh
Wow, oh oh that's the trick. That's Oh
No, yeah, we can do we can we can do it
Fuck
Hey
Look at that Christine. Channel everyone created level. You know what sir siren you get a life
I just really want to thank you guys for all the support on the game so far it really means to live
It's a super fun game. I think you guys are really gonna like it
It's so fun to see especially the character creations
I want to play more of your levels
So please go ahead and make some make some
Challenging one and see if you can beat me with the timing on them which I know you can't
Because I know you're all a bunch of lowlife level scumbags who don't know how to play video games
I'll leave a link to the description if you want to check out the game any support is highly appreciated
The game is still in early access
We're gonna add more and more and more, but it already has so much all the positive reviews
Thank you to everyone that left a review on the steam page as well for taking the time and do that I really have thought
a lot and
Just sharing the good world of ass which is always
Ass Thank You jacksepticeye and all the other youtubers that play the game as well so far even though you are god-awful at the game
You know it's okay. You can't be you can't beat me you just can't but at least you trying
Oh, that's cute that
Is a big-ass checkpoint boy? Oh? Hell yeah, I'm bouncing haha
Sorry, let me just finish his level
Hey
That's awesome all right. Thank you guys. I'm leaving like I'll see you in the next one. Goodbye squad fam